stonehenge peut-être que ce nom ne vous
est pas familier mais si je vous montre
ceci je pense que ça vous parlera
davantage quelle histoire se cache
derrière ce monument monolithique qui se
trouve au sud de l'angleterre que
symbolise ce cercle de pierres pour
trouver des éléments de réponse je vous
invite à partir en voyage avec moi et
beaune l'ess qui marraine ce douzième
épisode
c'est ma passion et je suis très
heureuse de vous en parler aux côtés de
fabien vous allez voir à quel point son
histoire est fascinante bienvenue dans
cabinet curieuse
[Musique]
un million c'est le nombre de visiteurs
qui viennent visiter le site de
stonehenge chaque année un million de
personnes attirées par le mystère et
l'atmosphère qui imprègne ce lieu chargé
d'histoire et ce n'est pas sans raison
nombreux sont les légendes qui gravitent
autour de ces roches l'une d'entre elle
raconte qu'un géant aurait construit
stonehenge sous les ordres de merlin
l'enchanteur merlin l'enchanteur qui
aurait conseillé aux rois aurelius
ambrosius d'apporter des pierres
magiques à cet endroit pour construire
une sépulture
curieuse les gens et j'adore cette
légende on a bien mieux aujourd'hui pour
expliquer le déplacement de nombreuses
pierres de plusieurs tonnes revenons un
peu en arrière peut-on remonter jusqu'à
la date de construction eh bien oui
puisque comme vous vous en doutez de
nombreuses fouilles ont déjà été
réalisées
jean paul ii moule archéologue et
professeur de protohistoire européenne
explique que la conception de ce
monument a débuté il ya plus de 5000 ans
l'une des questions qui nous intéresse
le plus c'est pourquoi pourquoi un tel
lieu à quelles fins et bien plusieurs
théories se bousculent au xviie siècle
l'une d'entre elles évoquent l'idée d'un
calculateur astronomique basé sur les
trous dobre les cinquante six trous qui
entourent l'édifice il s'agirait alors
de prédire les éclipses de lune une
autre théorie se base sur les gravures
retrouver sur les pierres des gravures
de dague de hache et de poignards à
l'âge du bronze stone age aurait pu
servir de plaque tournante du commerce
d'étain et d'or
s'il vient une autre interrogation
étonnant dans toute cette histoire c'est
la provenance de ces roches en effet les
pierres qui composent ce monument ne
sont pas toutes originaires de la région
d'un côté on a des blocs de grès
originaire d'une carrière située à une
trentaine de km du lieu ce sont les
pierres de sarcelles qui forment le
cercle extérieur d'un autre côté
certaines pierres semble venir encore
plus loin c'est le cas par exemple des
pierres bleues situe au centre de
l'édifice deux théories se sont d'abord
confronter à ce sujet soit elles
auraient été amenés ici pendant la
période glaciaire soit elle aurait été
transportée par des centaines d'hommes à
l'aide de cordes et de rondins durant
200 km depuis une carrière la 2e théorie
semble alors la plus cible on sait même
que ces pierres proviennent des colis de
présilly c'est dans l'ouest du pays de
galles et quand on sait ça eh bien il
faut savoir qu'un autre cercle de
pierres baptisé one moon a été érigé à
cet endroit quelques centaines d'années
avant stone age d'après des chercheurs
de l'university college london ces
pierres auraient été déplacés par ces
constructeurs au fil de la migration de
sa communauté en angleterre on sait que
stonehenge est en fait une copie de
windows le diamètre est l'alignement
sont en effet similaire ce qui confirme
que ce taux n'est que je n'ai pas
réalisé au hasard mais du coup comment
ces pierres de 2 à 50 tonnes ont-elles
atterri là trois théories se confrontent
soit elles ont été transportées via des
rondins soit sur des rails en bois
enduits de graisse soit grâce à un
système de roulements à billes un
système qui a d'ailleurs été testée par
une équipe de chercheurs et surtout
après les avoir amené jusque là comment
ont-ils pu construire ce monument les
deux tiers des pierres sont dressés
c'est déjà surprenant mais un tiers des
pierres de 45 tonnes sont carrément posé
à plus de 6 mètres du sol pour le
dresser il est possible qu'un
basculement dans un trou puisse être à
l'origine et pour hisser les roches
horizontale une rampe a pu être
utilisées on avance avec des hypothèses
plausibles sur le comment maintenant il
nous reste à découvrir le pourquoi
qu'est-ce que stonehenge symbolise pour
y répondre on peut déjà s'intéresser au
fameux trou dobrée qu'ils se trouvent
tout autour et qu'est ce qu'on trouve à
l'intérieur de ces trous
et bien désormais selon les chercheurs
de l'université de sheffield ces
emplacements étaient prévus pour un
groupe de personnes en particulier les
analyses ont démontré qu'il s'agissait
d'hommes plus précisément entre 20 et 40
ans des sommes que deux plutôt en bonne
santé selon le chercheur mike parker
personnes ces personnes auraient
probablement tenu un rôle politique
important peut-être même et est il issu
de la famille royale famille qui aurait
ordonné la construction de stonehenge du
coup on pourrait en déduire qu'il s'agit
d'un cimetière mais pas tout à fait
stone age fait partie d'un ensemble avec
plusieurs symboles connectés dans ce
complexe on trouve par exemple les du
ring toys une autre enceinte du
néolithique située à 3km de stone age
pour les archéologues
il s'agirait des vestiges d'un village
les personnes qui ont construit stone
age aurait peut-être habiter à cet
endroit il y à aussi l'avenue une voie
qui relie le fleuve à vonn a stone age
cette voie est aligné avec le soleil au
moment du coucher pendant le solstice
d'hiver et au moment du lever pendant le
solstice d'été d'après jean paul ii
moule il est clair que stone age et est
un temple ou un sanctuaire en rapport
avec le soleil en effet les choses sont
bien pensés puisque le soleil se lève
pile dans laxe du monument le jour du
solstice d'été le solstice d'été c'est
un moment très important pour beaucoup
de civilisations prendre en compte
l'alignement du soleil c'est un moyen
pour beaucoup d'entre elles de faire les
cérémonies au bon moment et d'être en
harmonie avec le cosmos l'archéologue
malgache rami l'iso zina explique un
autre élément intéressant sur le symbole
des mégalithes il affirme que ces
derniers représentés les ancêtres et
permettait de garder leur mémoire
vivante pour l'éternité vous vous
souvenez tout à l'heure quand je vous ai
parlé de won et bien on a une
explication là aussi concernant le
déplacement par le docteur parker
personnes qui expliquent le
démantèlement de wons et l'apparition de
stonehenge refaire partie d'une
migration plus vaste vers un axis mundi
où la terre et des cieux se retrouve en
harmonie
je vous ai perdu axis mundi jorand on
vous explique dans la mythologie axis
mundi que l'on peut traduire par axe du
monde et la connexion entre le ciel et
la terre
c'est comme si stone age était un point
de correspondance entre les dieux et les
hommes c'est une manière pour les hommes
de s'élever vers les dieux et pour les
dieux de déverser leurs bénédictions sur
les hommes ces anciens peuples auraient
peut-être emporté leurs monuments avec
eux comme un signe de leur identité
ancestrale dont il avait besoin pour
s'enraciner dans une nouvelle terre ont
résumé stone age aurait servi à la fois
aux rituels entourant la vie et la mort
mais aussi à se synchroniser avec les
événements célestes il faisait
certainement fils de temples à ciel
ouvert tel qu'on contre on aujourd'hui
quant aux personnes qui aurait érigé
cette oeuvre il pourrait s'agir des
droïdes ou des vikings stone age datant
d'une époque où nous n'avons pas encore
trouvé de trace de l'écriture nous
n'avons aucune documentation d'époque il
est donc encore le fief de nombreux
mystères ce site est aujourd'hui classée
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco et
continue de fasciner les visiteurs
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
merci beaucoup à beaune est d'avoir
participé à cet épisode j'invite tous
les adeptes d'archéologie et de fait
préhistorique étonnant à visiter sa
chaîne sans plus tarder je te remercie
fabien pour cette invitation et merci à
vous tous pour avoir regardé cette vidéo
si vous me connaissiez pas avait déjà
bonjour je m'appelle toujours fabien
olicard le prochain épisode de cabinet
curieux sera publiée le mois prochain on
va parler d'une secte avec megan morgan
garder la cloche activé comme ça vous
verrez passer la vidéo abonnez-vous
leaké d'ailleurs cette vidéo proposée
mois dans les commentaires les sujets
que vous aimeriez voir d'un cabinet
curieuse et n'oubliez pas que cabinet
curieuse existe parce que j'ai un
magazine qui s'appelle curieuse un vrai
magazine papier mensuel qui arrive tous
les mois dans votre boîte aux lettres
ici vous avez le sommaire du mois
prochain n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
vous avez le lien de la description ou
et même visité jusque le site pour lire
quelques articles gratuitement sur les
anciens numéros du magazine
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]
tous